[Música]
en realidad todo inicia
en 1976 cuando yo habitaba en el sur de
francia en un lugar que se llama mayor
ese vigor y yo tenía pues nueve años ya
saneado
y este
pues yo era niño así como la práctica
anterior un niño que le encantaba
divertirse explorar en particular donde
vivíamos era un lugar en el sur de
francia los pirineos donde hay montañas
relieve yo estaba encantado con la idea
de poder y de aprender esquiar y poder
disfrutar con mis dos hermanos
y pues
aprender también del lugar donde estaba
en un lugar diferente de mexico
y pues cuál fue mi sorpresa que no lo
logré por qué
enfermo de una cosa semana fiebre
reumática y que los doctores dijeron que
si metro
descuidado no me cuidaba bien pues ya
tener problemas con el corazón por el
resto de mi vida y todos mis sueños de
poder hacer algo interesante de poder
divertirme de poder ir a asia me en la
nieve aprender es que aprender esgrima
qué sé yo muchas cosas que yo tenía
oportunidad de hacer en ese momento si
la mina bajón porque porque el doctor me
necesita reposo total
veamos
niño
inquieto
con muchos sueños y pues me hace tanto
este es un momento singular es un
momento en donde algo sucede y pues los
metros singulares siempre nos dan estas
opciones yo tenía la opción de tirar a
llorar lamentarme sufrir y pasarle pues
el tiempo que me recetaron los doctores
que tenía que estar reposo total es
sufriendo
pues hay opciones en la vida siempre hay
una opción cuando y más cuando existen
estos lugares estos momentos estas
situaciones donde hay un cambio y podía
también pues tomar lo mejor de la vida y
hacer algo positivo de mi situación
eso cambió mi vida porque porque lo que
hice es aproveche ese tiempo para
aprender a hacer algo que
lamentablemente hablando los milenios ya
no se hace tanto y es leer
si yo aprendí a tomar cualquier libro
que calle en mi mano y primer leer y
ponerle a leer y leer y ver y esto este
pues marcó mi vida porque al final de
cuentas me dio la oportunidad de poder
hacer lo que realmente me apasiona en la
vida y estos son las matemáticas
sí
si bien se es curioso no un niño que
tiene muchos sueños que tienen muchas
ideas de pasárselo divirtiéndose en la
nieve a emprender esgrima correctiva con
sus hermanos conectarán los campos en
francia etcétera está muy chico como
para corre otras mujeres
y pues
me adentro en este tema de las
matemáticas que al final se trata de
entender al mundo que nos rodea psiquis
de expertas de matemáticas al final de
cuentas es un poquito como la filosofía
así donde estamos tratando de entender
nuestro mundo pero pues desde una
perspectiva un poquito más formal quizá
más rigurosa no sé no soy filoso
pero al final de cuentas todos somos un
poco porque nos gusta preguntarnos el
origen o el porqué en la vida etc y en
particular en las matemáticas el término
de singularidad se usa para aludir a
ciertas funciones que presentan
cualidades distintas o diferentes
así como la singularidad de enfermarme y
de la erupción
así en las matemáticas también existen
estas cosas en particular en matemáticas
yo me dedico a estudiar aproximar campos
vectoriales
pues
ya dije aunque quien sabe que sea eso
verdad bueno voy a tratar de explicarles
rápidamente qué significa un campo
electoral
en el caso de los particulares la imagen
que tenemos aquí es un campo vectorial
sobre el plano se hace una superficie
plana sobre un pedazo de papel y qué
significa que tengamos en cada puntito
del plano una flechita es un vector y
eso es lo que significa un campo de
crear en cada lugar del espacio ponemos
una flechita y esto es un campo
electoral podemos pensar en campos de
perales en el espacio de tres menciones
o el cuatro o ninguna en 2002 donde
quiera que lo querramos por
y bueno porque esas líneas que están ok
porque estas líneas lo que están
representando es qué pasaría si yo
dejara una partícula en el plano y
empezará a mover las de acuerdo a la
flechita que tiene justo debajo y
podemos ver que efectivamente es si hubo
una flechita en el origen producido en
una particular en el origen de una de
las curvas y la dejo que fluya con las
flechitas que están debajo de ella se
movería y tras ser y una curva como la
que vemos ahí ese es un campo vettel
bueno pues sí pero y eso para qué nos
sirve no es una pregunta que los
matemáticos no nos hacemos perfecto al
resto de gentes y para qué sirven las
matemáticas
en particular los campos vectoriales en
la vida real se encuentran en muchos
lugares pero en donde sea que haya
movimientos de partículas ahí va a haber
y en este caso está en la imagen donde
se ve que se puede utilizar los campos
lecciones para modelar el viento
en la imagen tomar el internet de un
programita muy bonito muy interesante
que nos da las condiciones climáticas
del planeta en este momento y si luego
ya lo consultor y tabares para ver otra
imagen completamente distinta pero que
nos está representando cómo es que se
mueve las partículas de aire en el
planeta
y eso qué bueno esto nos lleva a mi otra
pasión que es el huevo
vuelo en parapente en particular el
vuelo en parapente que es pues es una
actividad deporte fid yo realizo es como
digo una de mis pasiones
empecé con sueños de esquiar cetera no
lo logré pero sí logré goles y este lo
que se hace es aprovechar las corrientes
de viento para a través de un pedazo de
tela que hace el parapente yo creo que
vamos a ver cómo se infló
volar para aprovechar las corrientes
ascendentes y poder llegar a algún otro
lugar y en particular aquí en la imagen
vamos a ver dónde yo estoy volando y
estoy acercándome al aterrizaje que es
ese campo está ahí enfrente y pues es un
momento triste porque voy a dejar de
poder volar y de repente me encuentro un
momento singular porque por fin
encuentro una corriente ascendente de
aire y la tomo y empiezo a dar vueltas
alrededor de ese lugar donde está
ascendiendo la corriente y vuelvo a
adquirir de altura gasolina para poder
seguir mi web y claro es una película
esté un poquito más rápida para que me
alcance de tiempo
pero ese pedacito donde yo soy voy
subiendo por unos 78 minutos
y es otro ejemplo de un momento singular
una singularidad en particular de una
singularidad del campo vectorial
de la velocidad del viento de circular
ok entonces volvamos a las matemáticas
singularidad en general que significa
proceso que hemos estado hablando es una
palabra que ilusión tiene su origen en
el vocablo latino singular y estás que
trata de hablar de lo que no es como lo
otro o sea que no es común es diferente
es fuera de lo común el momento es
asombroso y en la imagen podemos ver
pues campo vectorial normalito común
donde todas las flechitas están
apuntando en la misma dirección y no
pasa nada
en la siguiente imagen vemos un lugar
donde las flechitas ya están haciendo
algo interesante y en el medio de ese no
es donde hay una singularidad esta
singularidad se más de tipo por lo los
matemáticos ya la conocen y han podido
estudiar explicarlo perfectamente bien y
entenderlo
la tercera imagen hay otra singularidad
de otro campo vectorial y en este caso
se ha museo
quién sabe que importa es otro lugar
donde efectivamente
la velocidad del campo se está
comportando distinto y en el mediocentro
la velocidad es cero
entonces ahí es próximo a 0 en este caso
sin embargo hay otros lugares donde los
campos de pérez se comportan en la
humedad completamente distinta y mucho
más complicado como el ejemplo que
tenemos aquí en este caso sea una
singularidad esencial y los matemáticos
no entendíamos cómo es que funciona
vamos a explicar esto
tras las y son son lugares donde la
cualidad que distingue algo de otras
cosas de su tipo su ser
y como matemático con nosotros no lo
estudiamos con ecuaciones que nadie más
entiende
con funciones sí y en particular en el
diagrama que está dibujado ahí aparece
una parte de este superior izquierdo
derecha
este algo que te una x grandota mx ese
es el espacio y el campo luego hay una
flechita hacia abajo en diagonal con una
si su x que son una función y esa es una
función que nosotros estudiamos y luego
está esta superficie
es la gráfica de la función y bueno
aunque las matemáticas un poquito más
agradables y más entendibles para
fíjense en mi momento en ningún momento
he puesto un número verdad porque las
matemáticas no son no son nada más de
números son de ideas son de conceptos en
particular las que me gustan a mí son de
imagen fría
y aquí tenemos una imagen de esa
singularidad y poco lo que habíamos
visto anteriormente y si se fijan
tendrían la misma tenemos el triangulito
de él en la imagen anterior y estamos
tratando de explicar de alguna manera es
el lenguaje descripciones en matemáticas
y si tomamos el campo vectorial que
tiene de poco con las flechitas y lo
hemos trasladado a otra cosa más
sencilla que son estas superficies
planas tan una encima de otra que se van
a pegar de ciertas para formar un
espiral
que sube y luego vuelve a bajar entonces
cada una de estas hojitas corresponde a
un sector de los que teníamos en el lado
izquierdo angular
con las flechitas y lo que hemos hecho
durante esta función que teníamos hace
rato lo que hacemos es el arte lo que
vemos es un hábito
pues que sé que él corre en la misma
dirección que deja de ser singular
claro a expensas de que de tener que
pegar más hojitas una encima de otra
programa una espiral y cuando se llega a
la parte superior espiral volverá a
bajar hasta que llegamos a la parte
inferior y volveremos a subir que ha
sido la pasamos pero lo que hemos hecho
es hacer algo que los milenios quieren
hacerlo hacer las cosas más sencillas
sin embargo pues siempre hay algo de que
entender de complicar
y bueno lo mismo podemos hacer con este
caso de las ingles esenciales en el que
tenemos que explicar el comportamiento
de esta singularidad que era mucho más
complicada porque como que de un lado
tenemos muchos polos y los grados muchos
ceros y lo interesante
esta es la explicación mediante esta
forma de verla
la singularidad se convierte en algo muy
sencillo porque nada más tenemos
espirales que suben y siguen subiendo y
siguen subiendo y nunca para dios
eso es algo que hemos estado trabajando
durante muchos años
con los campos de actores y otras
imágenes de otros campos de tutoriales
donde procuran estas singularidades y
que hemos logrado explicar cuando lo
vemos porque trabajo en conjunto con
personas de una memoria de lo visual y
sonora
pero bueno
regresando del web
en esta imagen vemos
dos vuelos del mismo lugar
un despegue en pátzcuaro michoacán en
donde se alcanza a ver como vamos
subiendo a través de la singularidad
vamos a tirarle subiendo agarrando
altura y luego tenemos la opción en este
caso la opción era irnos así
es el auto está atrás de esta imagen o
irme al proyecto de santamaría de
milliman gago quiere continuar por la
línea recta y llegar a otro look
entonces que quiero aportar con esto que
bueno las singularidades siempre son
lugares donde uno se va a enfrentar con
opciones así como en la gráfica anterior
imagen anterior teníamos la opción de
irnos a pax y los hacía vuelta a una
sesión doble última grado este en cuando
nos enfrentemos una singularidad en la
vida vamos a acceder a esas dos opciones
y estas dos opciones normalmente
ejemplifican un rompimiento que en
inglés rompimiento pues tiene dos
excepciones
que yo los que a mí me gusta expresarlas
porque porque me parecen muy
interesantes un es el frente a la mente
sufrir
y el otro que es más interesante es el
break truth que se trata de romper a
través de tener éxito de triunfar y como
mensaje final pues yo les quiero dejar
nomás para que lo tomen sus precisamente
el hecho de que las singularidades se
encuentran la clave del éxito muchas
veces
[Aplausos]
[Música]